y
[Música]
estas son las noticias de france 24 joe
biden es el nuevo presidente de eeuu
durante su discurso de investidura tras
jurar como presidente hizo un llamado a
la unidad nacional para preservar la
democracia
mientras tanto kamala harris se
convierte en la primera mujer
vicepresidenta de eeuu así como la
primera afroamericana
durante su discurso el nuevo inquilino
de la casa blanca dijo que la democracia
ha prevalecido e hizo énfasis en
defender la verdad
textualmente señaló que el desacuerdo no
debe conducir a la separación y que se
debe acabar con esta guerra no civil en
cuanto a los aliados internacionales
hablo de reparar las alianzas
varios líderes mundiales solicitaron al
ya presidente joe biden desde francia
emmanuel majo le da la bienvenida al
mandatario al acuerdo de parís sobre el
clima mientras tanto el papá francisco
le pide favorecer la reconciliación y la
paz con otras naciones israel canadá el
reino unido- y también la unión europea
dicen estar dispuestos a trabajar en una
agenda común
[Música]
muy buenas tardes bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález gracias por continuar con
nosotros comenzamos en eeuu a este país
tiene nuevo presidente el demócrata joe
biden ofreció un potente discurso en su
investidura en el que hizo un llamado a
la unidad nacional para cuidar la
democracia tal como lo había hecho en
discursos anteriores el mandatario
espera la unión de los estadounidenses
independientemente del partido político
con el que se estén identificando
biden aseguró que ejercerá su
administración para todos los ciudadanos
por igual la política no tiene que ser
un incendio lleno de ira que destruye
todo en su camino
debemos terminar esta guerra incívica
del rojo en contra del azul o lo rural
contra el urbano el conservadurismo
contra el liberalismo podemos hacer esto
si abrimos nuestra alma si todavía están
en desacuerdo está bien esa es la
democracia eso es eeuu
derecho al descenso en paz es una de las
salvaguardas de nuestra nación es su
mayor fortaleza escúchenme claramente el
desacuerdo no debe liderar a la de su 9
llevar a la desunión y yo le prometo eso
ustedes seré presidente para todos los
estadounidenses todos los
estadounidenses durante esta posición yo
baiden puso la mano izquierda sobre la
biblia mientras su esposa jill biden la
estaba sosteniendo lo curioso de esta
biblia es que fue la misma que yo baiden
utilizó en 2013 para la juramentación de
su segundo mandato como vicepresidente
de la entonces administración del
presidente barack obama vale la pena
decir que esta biblia no ha sido la
misma que han utilizado los presidentes
o los mandatarios a lo largo de los años
sino que ésta pertenece a su familia
hace décadas atrás
joseph ravinet baiden juró solemnemente
te llevaré a cabo fielmente el cargo de
presidente de los eeuu
y con lo mejor de mis capacidades
[Música]
preservar proteger y defender la
constitución de los eeuu con la ayuda de
dios felicidades y el presidente
[Aplausos]
uno de los temas que recalcó el
presidente joe biden fue la importancia
de la unidad entre los ciudadanos y por
ello recordó esa toma el capitol del
pasado 6 de enero
by then aseguró que la democracia de
eeuu prevaleció pese a estos hechos
violentos
así que en estos terrenos sagrados donde
hace unos pocos días la violencia buscó
sacudir los cimientos del capitolio nos
hemos reunido como una nación bajo dios
indivisible para llevar a cabo la
transición pacífica del poder como hemos
hecho por más de dos siglos
kamala harris se fue la primera en
juramentar en su cargo ella se convirtió
así en la primera mujer en ser
vicepresidenta de eeuu también la
primera afroamericana y la primera
persona de origen asiático o
descendiente de asiáticos en llegar a
este puesto en la unión americana
yo kamal a devin harris juro
solemnemente que apoyaré y defenderé la
constitución de los eeuu
contra todos los enemigos nacionales e
internacionales
que mantendré verdadera fe y lealtad a
los mismos
que asumo esta obligación en libremente
sin ninguna reserva mental o propósito
de evasión
y que cumpliré bien y fielmente
los deberes del cargo en el que estoy a
punto de entrar
que dios me ayude
en oakland en el estado de california de
la ciudad natal de kamala harris está
nuestra corresponsal susana mendoza
susana cómo se vive allí esta ceremonia
de posesión de la vicepresidenta como
transcurrió allí la jornada en la costa
oeste
pues buenas tardes aquí todo muy
tranquilo una jornada hasta ahora
tranquila y eso que se está viviendo
también en medio de fuertes medidas de
seguridad ya que las autoridades
bueno pues han advertido sobre posibles
protestas violentas a lo largo de este
día por ahora digo no estamos viendo
nada de eso eso sí en el capitolio de
este estado en sacramentos y se supone
que hay preparada una protesta de
activistas a favor de trump en
aproximadamente unas dos horas pero la
policía las autoridades han embargado
toda la zona por lo que es imposible
acceder dentro del capitolio
precisamente para evitar vivir escenas
como las el 6 de enero y aquí la
comunidad tanto de oakland como de san
francisco bueno pues aquí kamala harris
tiene tiene muy buena fama es una
política muy querida en general y es que
kamala harris nació aquí en oakland y se
forjó forjó su carrera política en la
ciudad de san francisco primero como
fiscal del distrito de esta ciudad
después dio el salto a la fiscalía
general de california y aunque este año
desgraciadamente por la pandemia no se
puede celebrar en las calles y las
autoridades también
a la comunidad que por favor no salga a
las calles debido a esta crisis de salud
eso sí hay gente hay personas que han
decidido homenajear a su manera a harris
como por ejemplo varios dueños de
restaurantes que han preparado menús
especiales hoy para la inauguración de
bailén y de kamala también hay incluso
un heladero que ha creado un sabor de
helado especial al que ha llamado kamala
harris y que según él sabe a vainilla
gracias susana por este reporte desde la
ciudad de oakland en el estado de
california joe biden el presidente de
eeuu tiene una larga carrera política
primero fue senador de ese país y luego
fue el vicepresidente de la nación en el
mandato de barack obama
a continuación demos una mirada a la
trayectoria del nuevo presidente de eeuu
la tercera fue la vencida y joe biden
llegó a la presidencia de eeuu el primer
stage en el sporting
a los ciudadanos de esta nación han
hablado nos han entregado una clara
victoria una contundente victoria
prometo no ser un presidente que dé vida
sino que una que no vea estados rojos o
azules solo estados unidos united states
con 77 años joven reúne casi cinco
décadas de carrera política nacido en
scranton pensilvania pasó la mayor parte
de su vida en el estado de delaware tras
graduarse de la escuela de derecho del
estado dirigió una exitosa campaña al
senado de eeuu en 1972
convirtiéndose en uno de los senadores
más jóvenes en el cargo
pero justo después de ganar las
elecciones su esposa y su hija de un año
murieron en un accidente de tránsito
consideró renunciar a su asiento pero
finalmente se mantuvo y se volvió a
casar en 1977 después de perder las
primarias demócratas de 2008 ante barack
obama se convirtió en su compañero de
fórmula
ambos terminaron forjando un estrecho
vínculo
muchos pensaron que biden se postularía
para la presidencia en 2016 pero una
nueva tragedia lo golpeó cuando su hijo
murió de cáncer cerebral
[Aplausos]
en 2020 bardem ganó la candidatura
demócrata a la presidencia entre una
lista de 27 aspirantes es reconocido por
su compromiso de capacidad de superación
pero el ala más izquierdista de su
partido critica su postura moderada en
la campaña by the end se destacó por
expresar empatía hacia los votantes y su
voluntad de luchar contra la pandemia
del hobbit 19 bailén ha prometido calmar
los ánimos y ha endurecido el tono
después de que manifestantes de trump
atacar en el capitolio impulsados por
acusaciones sin fundamento de un
supuesto fraude electoral
maiden ahora acusa a trump de atentar
contra los cimientos de la democracia
estadounidense
donald trump también se refirió al país
que le deja al nuevo presidente joe
biden en medio de la pandemia del cob y
19 que ha cobrado la vida de más de
400.000 personas solo en ese país
norteamericano aseguró que volverá sin
hacer algún tipo de referencia a ese
posible juicio político que podría
enfrentar en el senado que tiene en su
contra que de ser aprobado allí podría
quitarle la posibilidad de aspirar a un
segundo mandato presidencial en 2024 y
debo decirles que el futuro de este país
nunca ha sido nunca lo sido más
brillante espero que la administración
tengo una gran suerte y un gran éxito
creo que tendrán un gran éxito tienen
las bases para hacer algo realmente
espectacular y de nuevo lo ponemos en
una posición como nunca he estado antes
a pesar de la peor plaga
que nos ha tocado desde 1917 hace 100
años a pesar de eso a pesar de eso las
cosas que hemos hecho han sido
simplemente increíbles y nunca las pude
haber hecho sin ustedes simplemente es
un adiós los amamos estaremos de vuelta
de alguna forma
y como era de esperarse hay reacciones a
nivel internacional diferentes líderes
mundiales han manifestado ya han
felicitado al presidente de eeuu joe
biden
desde francia el presidente manuel marco
le dio la bienvenida al mandatario
nuevamente al acuerdo de parís que está
enfocado en la lucha climática al que
bardem recientemente investido volverá a
integrar ya que en la administración
anterior lo había retirado también el
papá francisco le pide volver a la
reconciliación y la paz con otras
naciones israel canadá al reino unido
también la unión europea dicen estar
dispuestos para trabajar en una agenda
común con la nueva administración
estadounidense
espero trabajar con ustedes para
fortalecer aún más la alianza entre eeuu
a israel para continuar expandiendo la
paz en el país y el mundo árabe y para
enfrentar desafíos comunes el principal
de ellos es la amenaza que representa
irán
y una de las 15 órdenes ejecutivas que
firmara el día de hoy el nuevo
presidente de eeuu joe biden y que
revierten las políticas instauradas por
el ex presidente de donald trump es la
de volver a formar parte de los acuerdos
de parís desde la capital francesa de
vic a olavarría nos tiene las
impresiones en este país europeo en
cuanto a esta decisión una de las cosas
que puso contenta francia tras la
victoria de joe biden fue la promesa del
candidato demócrata de reintegrar a su
país en el acuerdo del clima de parís
del año 2015 del que se salió
efectivamente en noviembre del año
pasado primero porque eeuu es el segundo
emisor de gases de efecto invernadero
del planeta es responsable de un 15 por
ciento de las emisiones y con el acuerdo
del clima de parís se comprometía a
reducir estas emisiones en un 25 por
ciento de aquí al año 2025 y con
respecto al año 2005 pero en segundo
lugar también porque eeuu es un
contribuyente económico muy importante
primero de la convención de naciones
unidas por el clima la que organiza las
cop y en segundo lugar del fondo verde
que es el que ayuda a los países en
desarrollo primero a disminuir sus
emisiones y en segundo lugar adaptarse
al cambio climático
pero reintegrando el acuerdo del clima
de parís la huella carbono de eeuu por
decirlo alguna manera no se reduce
demasiado por lo mismo los asesores
medioambientales del presidente electo
le han dicho que a través de decreto él
debería revertir 159 medidas que tomó en
contra del medio ambiente
donald trump también a través de decreto
entre ellas por ejemplo restablecer el
comité consultivo de la ciencia del
clima que debe preparar justamente eeuu
para el cambio climático el sabin center
de la universidad de columbia ha
aconsejado el presidente piden que
restablezca la protección de los océanos
los lagos y de las costas
justamente esa protección había sido
eliminada en el año 2017 y llevó por
ejemplo interrumpir un programa de
limpieza de los grandes lagos que son
los que dan agua a 40 millones de
estadounidenses y canadienses y en
tercer lugar sus asesores le aconsejan
que niegue el permiso al proyecto de
oleoducto keystone xl
que había sido autorizado por el
presidente de donald trump y al que se
oponen las comunidades autóctonas por
los graves daños ecológicos que puede
causar y que por cierto había sido
interrumpido es ese permiso en noviembre
del año pasado por un juez de eeuu con
esto llegamos al final de las noticias
en france 24 los dejamos con estas
imágenes en vivo desde la ciudad de
washington de la caravana presidencial
que se dirige ya hacia la casa blanca la
residencia oficial del presidente de
eeuu en unos minutos regresamos con una
actualización de noticias aquí en france
24 siga con nosotros gracias por la
sintonía
[Música]